alors aujourd'hui le premier ministre a
écrit aux maires des 20 grandes villes
de france et présidente dijon métropole
pour justement mettre en place des
actions de prévention en cas d'une
deuxième vague donc une réunion se
tiendra demain la préfecture avec l'
agence régionale de santé pour voir s'il
est pertinent ou pas et bien d'imposer
le port du masque dans certaines rues à
dijon donc ça pourra intervenir dans les
jours qui viennent
oui je enfin on souhaite vraiment
travailler en étroite collaboration avec
l'agencé régionale de santé la
préfecture donc si effectivement le taux
de reproduction du virus s'accélère et
qu'il est pertinent de prendre cet
arrêté
on le prendra fin la préfecture le
prendra maintenant il faudra aussi qu'on
se donne des moyens de le faire
appliquer respecter